there's two lifetime movies that are
coming out i'm going to show you two of
them trailers for two
the first one mike
when you think of shock jocks what do
you think of well the
howard stern that's a great one um don
imus
that's a good one uh open anthony lex
and terry
uh a bunch of guys okay what about wendy
williams
oh you didn't say trap shock johnny no i
just said
sure okay yeah no i don't never really
think of wendy williams wendy williams
has her own life type movie because of
all that
they people watch this and they said
wendy williams
needs a lifetime movie she also produced
and wrote the movie well yeah because
there's not enough representation
in she's not like she's not right
you're sure i'm not positive i don't
ever want to you know i haven't seen the
goods
right but i'm assuming i'll take your
word for it are you ready for a great
movie yeah let's see this dude's movie
it's a woman
it's your girl wendy williams and the
mic i am here to stay
wendy williams is not going anywhere i'm
gonna come in like a hurricane it's a
trailblazer
hey so whitney are you still using drugs
wendy williams i hate wendy williams why
well besides the obvious reasons because
it's it's another one of these like
artificially inflated propped up people
that like her tits nobody would care
about if
you know there weren't blogs writing
like you wouldn't think she was fabulous
if you didn't have 500 blogs telling you
how fabulous she was
supposed to give you a talk show
millions of people turn on the radio to
listen to me you're the star
i am going to tell it like it is so is
this whole movie just sucking wendy
williams dick
she produced it and wrote it and it's
just all about how great she is
she made a movie about herself but i
mean again not only
about herself but it seems like there's
no obstacle to overcome it's literally
the whole movie is just
i'm awesome yeah how [ __ ] cool am i
it's pretty like even private parts like
there was like he got fired and then it
was like
like there was a little bit of stuff in
there but like this is just gonna be
like god damn how cool is wendy williams
i'm becoming a real business and i've
been trusting you to take care of all of
them
you're self-indulgent you're
narcissistic you got a coke habit
he's having a baby with her before i had
you
i had me and not you nor so this is
basically her doing a movie about a hit
piece on one of her managers i guess
that she doesn't like
also or like a lover love her love her
manager love her slash manager because
you by the way when you get a manager it
should always be somebody you're [ __ ]
that's always
i have a good idea step one in business
or in entertainment you get a manager
that you're sleeping with so that you
have personal and business intertwined
together it's really fun
worked out for homer you nor anyone else
have a power
country singer yes yes
[Laughter]
nor anyone else have the power to take
away my gifts
i'm gonna bring the heat
[Music]
hold on did you see media mogul is she
though
you know who's a media mogul who's a
media mogul mike rupert murdoch okay
and then when he was because rupert
murdoch ted turner maybe
it goes rupert murdoch wendy williams
ted turner
that's the order that's unbelievably
[ __ ] like i'm actually mad i'm not
even gonna laugh at that i'm mad
ted turner and i know ted turner was a
lefty piece of [ __ ] but
billionaire ted um an american
institution
you say we want but that that was a
famous mustache a famous tower in
atlanta like ted turner was a big deal
this is a [ __ ]
insult you've besmirched the name of ted
turner
not on mercer's watch no i'm sorry but
are you sure they didn't
mean to call her a media mogui no like
it's
wet you don't get her wet and don't let
her feed her after midnight trust me the
last thing i ever want to do is get
wendy williams wet
[Laughter]
because then you're in trouble that's
gross i think consent would be optional
with this
[ __ ] power forward for the [ __ ]
jazz
wendy palma basketball it's [ __ ]
terrible
[Laughter]
she was either gonna be a shock jack or
a tight end for the patriots
yeah or be just a a regular attraction
at the nba dunk contest every year
oh [ __ ] i will
turn this city out a lifetime original
movie
you're gonna eat the city out
wendy williams premiere saturday january
wendy williams is one of those women
that could throw out the opening pitch
at a baseball game and then afterwards
the catcher has to actually take his
mitt off and go oh
[ __ ] man are you excited for january
you need to be finished let me finish my
sentence are you excited for january
30th to watch the wendy williams movie
not at all oh somebody doesn't like me
media moguls no i do like real ones
they're fascinating to read about
you're not by the way you're not a media
mogul until you own a building that's my
rule
you have to own a building you have to
have you have to have some kind of
high-rise building that your company
owns
that it does all of its giant media
business out of
then you're a mogul if you're renting a
[ __ ] let me tell you something if
you're renting a [ __ ] office suite in
ventura california
so you can sign your own books that
you're selling on amazon you're not a
media mogul
suck a dick well
i have another lifetime movie that i
would like to present to you this is
another lifetime movie that's true by
the way my neither michael i have seen
this trailer
we've only seen the screenshot of them
so excited for this this will be coming
out next week
i am so excited for this um should i
just play the trailer
yeah december 13th it premieres
what the hell are you doing a lifetime
original mini movie
you don't answer my proposal and now
you're not answering my call
i think i'm falling for the new chef
[Laughter]
it's just such an iconic look you can't
help but know right away
what's happening here
[Laughter]
i want to point out that this isn't a
bit i want to show you this from the
original lifetime
lifetime okay
jessica is falling for harlan the cook
they're calling him kfc slater
yes he's kfc slater
oh god oh no oh god
no leave jessica alone and skip town
he has a secret recipe that's going to
change
sure it's 12 herbs and spices what's the
problem
he has a musical recipe that's going to
change the world i'd be
like dude you gotta [ __ ] like dude look
mario lopez look man i don't know how
much they paid you for this but
i hope it was a lot of [ __ ] money
because this is ridiculous
secret recipe that's going to change the
world marlin claims to have some secret
recipe a secret recipe
spare me we all have our secrets
if you marry my daughter i promise
there'll be more long weekends in your
future
mom i have to tell you something we have
a problem
secret's out chicken man i'll take
secrets out chicken man i mean this is
clearly a commercial for kfc but like
how much do you think they paid for that
but it's not just a commercial they're
doing a mini more i know it's a mini
movie but it's like the
no of course they paid commercials yeah
it's like uh when they did the little uh
like you brought up earlier when they
had the kfc
the kfc georgia gold honey barbecue
battle royal at like wrestlemania or
whatever ugh
chicken man i'll take care of this
ruining
everything just kill him already where
the hell are you
harlan sanders the new chef
colonel said why but why
is my question i get that he is i know
who he is and i know
he's playing the question that's more on
america's mind is
why why did you do this
in a recipe for seduction
by the way good name i want to i want to
do a call back to something we discussed
earlier
hear me out on this now imagine if this
was just an snl sketch
this trailer it would be way better than
anything
else no dude that's the funniest thing
they came out with here is the funniest
thing snl started ten years
if this just imagine the [ __ ] i gotta
remind you guys
this is a real movie that lifetime's
doing sunday december 13th
12 p.m but if in the context of a comedy
sketch this would have been brilliant
you would have been like wow i don't
know who wrote that sketch
that was [ __ ] the most bizarre [ __ ]
i've ever seen but this is real this is
i think we could all agree with this
movie now that we have to go back right
if there's any way like a wormhole or a
time machine if there's any
if superman can fly backwards around the
planet everyone would fly off the planet
by the way if you did that
no i've seen the movie it just this time
went back and then lois lane got cured
of
her rights or whatever i don't know not
have a drug problem
that's for sure
she certainly didn't get any better at
swimming no it's terrible
um look i for one am very happy about a
recipe for seduction and i will be
watching this movie when it comes out i
need this in my life like i've already
told royce i'm like this
this might end up being a d live only
night wave episode i might have to sit
there and watch
this entire thing
premieres december 13th at noon
you know it's gonna be a smash hit on
wednesday presented by kentucky fried
chicken
um yes i know i mean i i'm pretty sure
it wasn't presented by wendy's
i am very can we get more of these now
can we get a wendy movie i'm actually
fine with that i mean this is better
like you said than snl than any other
[ __ ]
why not remember will ferrell made the
the lifetime movie and like took it
seriously as a bit
yeah like a couple years ago will
ferrell
was like i want to make a shitty
lifetime movie and people are like oh
you're going to make it funny he goes
no no no i am going to he wants to just
do a deadpan
yeah serious lifetime movie yeah yeah oh
yeah he did oh yeah he did
and it was called a deadly adoption
it was him and kristen wiig i'll just
play the trailer
we might as well it's only a minute long
he did this
2015. check this out
the agency called and they have a new
birth mother they want us to meet
i'm scared too so bad
[Music]
i love that will ferrell just did this
because he felt like
he was just bored and he said i want to
do it he got paid nothing for it too
like he barely got paid money well he's
got beyond [ __ ] you money yeah
like he's he's he's fine will ferrell's
fine
so he took it because again they thought
is it going to be a comedy
no they him and kristen weak took it a
hundred percent
seriously that's great and did the home
like that's a commitment to a bit that
i'll never understand
i mean that's next level i have given
anything to see the bloopers from that
movie yes
i i wonder they have to be out there but
i know 2005 they gotta be
uh let's see here you know you can't
deliver those lifetime movie lines
without a lot of laughing
oh yeah you know